[Musique]
la can le 33e marché international du
disque et de l'édition musicale s'est
ouvert le midem rassemble les grandes
sociétés de production et de
distribution ainsi que les labels
indépendants qui se livrent souvent une
bataille très vives mais ils ont tous en
commun une inquiétude la voc de plus en
plus grande de la copie via les
ordinateurs des cd de musique
pour certains c'est du piratage et un
manque à gagner reportage daniel
wolfromm et bernard enflait sur internet
pour pouvoir chercher des des musiques
on est donc on les cherche au format mp3
compressés en fait il s'agit de
rechercher un serveur il y en a des
dizaines sur internet qui proposent des
listes de chansons comme celle ci on
enregistre ensuite le titre pour le
transférer sur son ordinateur et le
dupliquer sans perte de qualité sur un
seul disque
on peut ainsi gravé l'équivalent de 10
cd soit 200 titres
[Musique]
ce qui est bien tout ça qu'on peut on
peut écouter les chansons en même temps
qu on en cherche le transfert dure
environ un quart d'heure pour un seul
titre
maintenant je laisse j'ai plus besoin
d'être connecté sur internet je peux me
déconnecter c'est fini j'écoute j'écoute
le morceau quand je veux et si j'ai
envie je peux le mettre sur un cd à
leurs mirettes du graveur et après je
les écoute sur ma chaîne je vais
l'emmener chez des amis pour l'écouter
d'un côté vous considérez comme un
pirate ou pas non non non parce que
disons que je fais pas de commerces
vraiment mais il dit à tous ceux qui en
profitent pour revendre leur copie grâce
à ces graveurs de cd en vente libre à
partir de 2500 francs alors vous pouvez
lutter contre ça alors pas de trois
façons la première phase on a les
technologiques
c'est de convaincre les industriels par
des négociations ça ne sera pas facile
de limiter au moins une seule copie le
nombre de copies possible à partir d'un
cd vierges la deuxième deuxième moyen
d'avoir des rémunération pour la copie
privée
et puis la troisième chose c'est d'avoir
un droit éventuellement d'autorisation
de diffusion de musique notamment sur
internet parce que sinon et bien
effectivement sans rémunération n'y a
pas d'investissement dans la création
ces systèmes qui va mourir de lui-même
pour les maisons de disques le manque à
gagner devient préoccupant le quart du
marché pourraient être perdus dans les
prochaines années si rien n'est fait
d'ici là
principale victime de ce commerce
parallèle les auteurs compositeurs jean
claude vannier a écrit des chansons pour
des dizaines d'artistes gainsbourg jonas
nougaro julien clerc je trouve que c'est
méprisant par rapport aux artistes et
aux propositions je trouve sympa très
élégant cette idée là que on peut se
servir de ce que les gens ont fait avec
coeur et en faire n'importe quoi ils
vont donner éventuellement gratos quoi
sans payer pour convaincre les jeunes de
ne plus copié leurs morceaux préférés la
sacem qui gère les droits d'auteur va
lancer une campagne d'information la
tâche s'annonce plutôt rude
vous achetez encore souvent des cd ou
pas c'est dès maintenant à cd 2 titres
ça coûte 34 ans et la deuxième chanson
elle est toujours pourri à partir du
moment où il ya plus d'argent dans le
système
le 3è 4è disent que tu aimes bien il
sortira plus tard quand vous copier un
enregistrement vous avez exactement la
même chose que cela discussions
s'éternisent et ne convainc personne
monsieur forest vous avez du boulot
ceci annonce en fait le bouleversement
du droit des auteurs et des créateurs
avec en toile de fond une révolution
dans l'édition musicale
[Musique]